foreign
to prescription painkiller drugs more
than 100 000 died from the drug during
the pandemic alone
it's brought death and misery to
millions of Americans a fatal fentanyl
overdoses fueling a national opioid
crisis we call it the new epidemic but
the leading producers of these drugs are
no longer pharmaceutical companies they
are Mexican cartels and criminals
when you have synthetically produced
drugs this is a complete Game Changer so
what has driven this shift to Illegal
production and consumption of synthetic
drugs this resembles more than like the
gig economy
and what does this diversification of
revenue streams say about the future of
the notorious Mexican cartels
and huge Advantage for these groups is
also you don't have to provide anything
but violence on a local level
a remote corner of the rural Mexican
state of Sinaloa
these two men are illegally cooking
Fentanyl
fentanyl is an opioid drug consumed by
millions north of the Border in America
[Music]
fentanyl is not difficult to cook if you
know the recipe one reason why business
is booming for producers
[Music]
this boom in an illegal production of
fentanyl has been driven by Rising
demand in both Mexico and America
fentanyl has been legally prescribed and
distributed in America since the 1960s
as an anesthetic it's time now for
surgery at this veteran but the recent
spike in illegal production and
consumption marks a new chapter in the
country's opioid crisis opioid addiction
has affected millions of Americans for
over two decades and some analysts say
the crisis has now entered a third phase
the first phase was uh prescription
drugs I was Oxycontin that created a
very large population dependent users
three four million pregnant users when
the DEA and the US government realized
what was happening with with the
prescription drugs and they started
putting the screws on on Physicians this
demand shifted to heroin the illegal
actors that work in this market realized
that fentanyl provide a much better
value to volume ratio than error in the
U.S customs seized five tons of fentanyl
in 2021 more than double the amount
during the previous year
although the volumes seized may seem
relatively small one attraction of
fentanyl for criminals is that a little
goes a very long way compared to Natural
opioids such as heroin for every 50 tons
of occurring you need to smuggle one ton
of alphanta because of potency
production and trafficking of fentanyl
are now growing revenue streams for
Mexican cartels and criminals
in Mexico you've traditionally had
production of heroin and marijuana and
you've had drafting of cocaine from
Colombia
the Mexican cartels had Diversified
their criminal portfolio in the drug
World by focusing increasingly on
synthetic drugs
heroin and cocaine require farms and
Manpower much like legitimate businesses
cartels and criminals are attracted by
opportunities to reduce overhead costs
it's estimated that fentanyl can be
produced at one hundredth of the cost of
heroin
the precursor chemicals required to make
fentanyl are relatively cheap
you can have me a whole bunch of precurs
it might just be a few thousand dollars
and you're producing millions of dollars
worth of drugs so the profit margins
there are huge
although there is often talk of fentanyl
Labs the reality is production is
low-tech with no need for expensive
equipment nor training a readily mobile
lab like this can make a kilo of
fentanyl in a day with just two people
when you have synthetically produced
drugs this is a complete Game Changer
these Labs can be anywhere you're not
depending on being close to the crops
you need some knowledge of basic
chemistry and disregard for human life
that's basically what you need to
produce a large amounts of fentanyl you
don't need a large industrial facility
the market forces of globalization mean
the supply chains for illegal synthetic
drugs production mirror those of
millions of legitimate Goods
in today's Global Marketplace legitimate
industrial manufacturers often look to
China to supply materials and chemicals
and it's no different in the case of the
precursors needed for fentanyl cooking
producers exploit the huge volume of
legal global trade to smuggle in these
chemicals
you have a huge port in Mexico including
the port of manzanillo Colima the port
of Lazaro Cardenas the port of Veracruz
first you have a lot of corruption in
the authorities in the ports but also
could be quite hard to know what they're
looking for sometimes you say okay what
are the precursors
for Fentanyl and you look it up and
these are like
a476321b it's like how these people know
and keep up with what they're looking
for to bust it
trainer has been much more effective in
controlling manufacturing center or past
two three four five years uh but less so
in controlling access to precursors so
what you're seeing is that something of
a near Shoring process where Centennial
production is coming from China to
Mexico
for those cooking fentanyl the risks to
personal health are high
companies
[Music]
Cooks have been said to die from the
inhalation and exposure to the chemicals
just as in the legal business World
workers are prepared to stomach risks in
return for the promise of high Rewards
the average daily salary in Mexico is
just over 23 US dollars a day but these
Cooks say they make four times that
around 100 a day
[Music]
like some well-established legitimate
businesses built on particular revenue
streams the notorious Mexican cartels
have successfully adapted their business
models in response to traditional
revenue streams declining synthetic
drugs are helping to make up for a drop
in income from marijuana the
legalization of marijuana in 18 U.S
states has cost the cartels billions in
revenues
from 2015 to 2019 marijuana seizures by
the U.S authorities decreased
significantly reflecting a decline in
Black Market production in Mexico
in 2021 for the first time seizures of
synthetic drugs were larger than cocaine
and heroin seizures
foreign
foreign
the changing preferences of consumers in
rich countries often dictate which
products are manufactured in the
developing world the supply chain of
synthetic drugs from China and Mexico is
fueled by the rising demand in America
back in Sinaloa this producer says
turning fentanyl into pills provides the
best bang for buck requiring less
Manpower for mass production
s
pills are appealing to traffickers
because they can be easily distributed
either by direct orders on the dark net
or by smuggling over the border to the
U.S
crane
is
foreign
good branding and marketing tends to pay
off for businesses and synthetic drugs
producers have proved Adept at these two
turning fentanyl into pills has
broadened its appeal to consumers in
America
they can be packaged as relief
prescription pills which appear similar
to the painkillers sold by legal
pharmaceutical companies during the
first phase of the opioid crisis
and they're more palatable to
middle-class Americans than heroin
the opioid crisis in the United States
also changed the nature of the Mexican
drug trade because less and less people
used heroin particularly injected
themselves with Heroin which was
regarded as the junky drug and therefore
dirty and socially unacceptable this in
no small part fed the increase in the
use of pills
it's not only Innovative Sales
techniques where the synthetic drugs
business mirrors Trends in the
legitimate business world
the business model of Mexican drug
cartels has been compared by analysts to
large franchises like Walmart
but in recent times once large cartels
have fragmented and splintered
production of synthetic drugs has come
to rely Less on Affiliated members of
established cartels and more on
freelance subcontractors the global gig
economy has reached the black market
this resembles more than like the gig
economy than what we imagined as a
large-scale kernel Syndicate as
portrayed in Narco Series in Netflix or
whatever
we're really looking at our universes of
production of membership and of
belonging as it were end of
participation in these markets that are
highly decentralized and are being fed
by a plethora of semi-independent
semi-autonomous participants as such
it's a highly decentralized a highly
resilient uh business and organizational
model the production of fentanyl has in
many ways democratized the drug Market
this democratization of the narcotics
Market is changing the structure of
criminal groups in Mexico and breaking
up some of the traditionally powerful
franchises
where there were once eight large
criminal conglomerates only two remain
recognizably in this form
but there are now an estimated 200
smaller active non-state armed illegal
groups these smaller groups are leaner
and more flexible
many have Diversified their criminal
activities in search of easier profits
more gangs probably don't have the word
with all four large-scale drug
trafficking but they will have the war
with all four extortion theft kidnapping
for a more breath or reactivity their
income stream is probably more
Diversified than what you have to say 25
years ago
from kidnapping for ransom and human
trafficking to fuel theft and extortion
of avocado Farmers this trend towards
diversification looks likely to continue
if you look at Industries like the
avocado industry with those are billion
dollar markets and a huge Advantage for
these groups is also you don't have to
provide anything but violence on a local
level it's a hydro-headed business model
that brings in huge numbers in a very
fragmented decentralized fashion Mexican
criminal groups have really become
multi-commodity entrepreneurs over the
past a decade and a half
oh nice crime drug traffickers in Mexico
I've adapted uh made a huge amount of
money and their networks have become
these monsters that have helped
destabilize this country
hello I'm Tom Standish Deputy editor at
The Economist if you'd like to learn
more about this topic click on the link
opposite thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe
thank you